you know Liz Warren she's the former a
Native American princess who gave up
truth-telling to cash in on telling more
lies and her latest fundraising email
she brings up how she was visibly
pregnant when quote the president told
her the job would go to someone else
it's another story in which she portrays
herself as the oppressed faking
victimhood to gain an edge over others
including real victims however her
pregnant victims story fell apart when
school board records obtained by the
free beacon shows the school offered her
a new contract
she quit anyway backing up the tale she
told back in 2007 when she said she left
by choice of course all politicians lie
those who say they don't our line
Warren's lies however fit a pattern its
victim karaoke an opportunistic
deception to exploit the plight of
others it's no different than parking in
a handicapped space and faking a limp
Jessie it's fraud now Liz claims her
native-american ruse was an honest
mistake but got her PR as the first
minority woman in Harvard Law which was
so heavily promoted by her and by
Harvard but when she knew that ski
scheme was imploding she paraded that
pathetic DNA test proclaiming her Native
American blood but a toaster had more
that wasn't an honest mistake
so his Biden gets hit by a Ukraine
boomerang she's now the front-runner
will this new lycost her in 2020 perhaps
but if she loses she can just lie again
and say that she won I mean whoever did
that before right Hilary so um
Dana yes I noticed in you notice that
the media are signaling support for Liz
throughout this playing it down the
focusing on conservatives pouncing on
her deserves pouncing on the fact that
they're like and actually I don't it's
pretty interesting when you talk about
as a viewer yes
I don't think that this new thing about
the contradictions in her story from
2007 and 2019 was put forward by a
conservative I truly believe that was
opposition research put out by one of
the other 20/20 Democrats and yet then
the media says the Conservatives are
pouncing yes they said like I think they
would should trace that back and find
out who really did it now her defenses
are going to work with the primary
voters right she's got women that are
talking and they like they can identify
with somebody being fired because I got
pregnant look if it's not true so in the
New York Times in that article it wasn't
until the sixteenth paragraph that they
say oh actually there was a
contradiction and there were these
documents everything so I think she
won't really feel the pain of all of
this until the fall of 2020 if she does
become the nominee because then remember
it'll be about a character question yeah
and then everybody will have a chance to
decide so she'll probably pay for it
later what why Trump will eat this up if
she becomes the nominee right Scott this
uh pattern of pretending to be a victim
well if you want to present it as that I
mean Dana and I disagree about where
this comes from I don't think liberals
are exactly giving leaking information
to the free beacon but that's what that
say was I think anyway anyway but I
think that I mean to me
she's been under attack for a while I
remember that story about she had an
affair with a 24-year old marine and
that story well I missed that one
me too yeah because it was bogus and I'm
glad you missed it but I mean well you
brought you just brought it up yeah
because it was another bogus story I was
it cover it I don't know but I would say
this I am surprised that people don't
say hey what was the context of this
because they say everything is premise
here on the school board saying we will
renew you for the next year right
without realizing that you now have
teachers saying to the reporters all
over the country oh yeah that was the
policy but if you could hide your
pregnancy then they wouldn't know they
would renew you and then once you became
pregnant then they would say hey we got
a heart in 2007 is she on tape doing an
interview saying that she made a
decision on her own she it's her own
words only we had a pregnant woman here
to discuss this
yeah Jedediah wasn't ours identifying a
pregnant woman we both pointed to Jessie
so well listen she's a liar and she's a
good liar
she's a really good liar I think she has
an incredible gift that she's able to
deceive and still be popular Hillary
Clinton does not have that gift I think
when she lied about her emails and she
lied repeatedly people held her
accountable for that I don't know if
that will wind up with Warren I think it
still remains to be seen but I think
it's pretty clear I mean what Dana's
saying is 100% true in 2007 you're
telling one story and then all of a
sudden now since 2017 you're out on the
campaign trail you want to be popular
you cultivate this story I think we
should talk to the leadership at the
school at the time I think we should get
to the bottom of the story but the thing
is I don't know if it matters because
when when that when that whole thing
with our heritage that was pure deceit
she goes and takes his DNA test she gets
backlash from the Cherokee community she
she obviously lied I mean 1/1000 24th
this or that it was ridiculous
and she's still rising in the polls so I
don't know if it's just that Democrats
and the base don't have anywhere else to
go because Joe Biden is so disappointing
that they don't care all right Jess I
want to hear more about this love affair
with a Marine
I think the point is this she lies not
about crowd size she lies about core
components of who she is her race and
her baby so those are a little more
significant than a little embellishment
the other thing is there's many more
politicians that have much more to
overcome
besides Liz Warren Liz Warren had a
pretty good middle-class girl great
education her first husband worked for
IBM she has a million dollars in the
bank plus she used to be a Republican
and now she's sitting pretty as a US
Senate so as you said she feels a little
inadequate maybe it's white guilt or
insecurity about maybe she didn't have
the struggle that other people did and
she needs to like you said sing that
victim karaoke a little bit louder to
get ahead and if the free beacon broke
that I will check it out but I think
that they went to the school they went
and looked at the actual records yeah I
am I will say this this show is pregnant
with thought thank you